it's big news that bill and melinda  gates are getting a divorce especially  because the couple does not appear to  have a prenup but the thing that i kept  seeing in  all of the news articles reporting on  this divorce is that melinda gates in  filing for the divorce  said that their marriage was  irretrievably broken  tons of people have locked on to that  language but i'm sorry to report that  that is just simply the standard for a  no-fault divorce in the state of  washington where they are filing for  divorce  to get a no-fault divorce in washington  one of the parties has to allege  that the marriage or domestic  partnership is quote irretrievably  broken that's just simply the law it's  not salacious in any way that's just  simply what you have to allege to get a  divorce so  sorry for those looking for drama that's  just the law and i'll see you  in court